well in less than two weeks raider
nation will pack
allegiant stadium to get a look at the
2021 version of the las vegas raiders
but
before the team debuts in its first
preseason game
there is practice and today it was a
little bit different at camp
sports director chris matthews here to
tell us why chris yeah it kind of was
the players put on those pads today
there was a little popping going on at
the intermountain healthcare and
performance center a little more giddy
up in their step
when the pads are on it's go time
becomes a little more legit
and the players will tell you they know
when this day arrives it's always kind
of a
rite of passage into the football season
am i right
oh absolutely i mean that's kind of i
think that's standard you know first day
with pads
you know guys are excited guys ready to
hit you know you haven't had the pads on
in months so it's a it's an excitement
thing um you know guys just out there
hitting
um you know it feels faster you know
things just
just one of those those kind of things
you circle on camp when the first day of
camp you see we go in you got pads on
and it's like a
day you kind of it leads up to it so
definitely definitely an intensity level
um you know coaches want to see guys you
know play physical and see what they got
so there's definitely
you know it definitely raised the bar on
days like today also at today's practice
there were a handful of former raiders
they watched and tonight they will be
guests at a
team dinner inside a legion stadium